let's count down the best Snoopy
summertime moments from season three
number eight Sandy Simple Pleasures my
grandpa always says when it comes to
Simple Pleasures nothing beats a sand
castle
[Music]
except the tide
number seven settle in for a staycation
I'm glad you decided to stay home for a
change Snoopy after all there's more to
life than sitting around drinking root
beer
[Music]
foreign
number six beware of picnic Pirates
[Music]
[Applause]
number five remember to stay hydrated
foreign
number four Snoopy keeps his cool Snoopy
I like you as much as the next person
that's why I feel so comfortable asking
you to please get your dog house out of
my pool
[Music]
thanks
number three snoopy catches a game
oh you're Snoopy
okay
number two time for a bird and Beagle
bath
[Music]
and number one ice cream strategies no I
ask you Charlie Brown is there a more
delicious puzzle to solve on a hot
summer's day then how to properly eat an
ice cream cone
for instance there's the chomper
[Music]
that method is not without its risks
here's another
side swiper
rats
also has a downside
you call that
a complete mess
[Music]
foreign